c'est un johan jégou concentrés et
qu'ils regardent ces joueurs se
préparent l entraîneur des u19 du
football olympique plaisir roi prépare
le déplacement de dimanche à saint leu
la forêt pour le 4e tour de la coupe
gambardella après l'exploit du mois
dernier face aux ulis qui évolue trois
divisions au-dessus les yvelinois
veulent poursuivre l'aventuré
l'équipe valdoisienne est loin de les
impressionner elle qui évolue pourtant
deux niveaux plus hauts en division
d'honneur régionale
c'est qu'on n'est pas favoris donc on
prépara comme les autres matches et puis
le bas après on verra c'est un feeling
d'accord de la gambardella c'est comme
ça quand vous dit chez nous on a la
dalle on a n'a plus envie de gagner que
d'habitude parce qu'on joue contre des
grosses équipes donc on essaye toujours
de donner plus donc c'est ça qui fait la
diff
côté tactique pas de changement
l'entraîneur ne veut pas revoir la
recette qui a fait son succès on va
garder au regard des en gros les schémas
qu'on a déjà mis en place depuis le
début de saison qu'ils ont plutôt bien
fonctionné plutôt un bloc défensif bas
en essayant d'aller jouer et d'aller
jouer le contre ce sera certainement la
solution la solution pour battre une
équipe une équipe qui joue active de
division dessus de nous donc on pense se
mettre en place dès ses premières larmes
reste tout de même à oublier le faux pas
lors de la dernière journée de
championnat pour sa première défaite de
l'année l'olympique plaisir voix
s'étaient inclinés 4 à 0 4 0
frack ça nous a remis ça nous a remis
dans le bain moussant le thé encore un
peu sur un nuage après à la dsr on
n'avait pas n'a pas encore fait des
fêtes jusqu'au depuis le début de
championnat donc le 4 0 ça peut lui
faire que du bien c'est mauvais on a
perdu mais moi ça peut ça peut nous
faire que du bien au niveau
au mental coup d'envoi du 4e tour de la
gambardella dimanche 14h30 sur le
terrain de saint leu